BASED ON GOOD INTENTIONS.
>> Sean: SEAN.
WEST COAST NEWSROOM TONIGHT,
TURNING POINT USA COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR CANDACE OWENS
CONFRONTED BY PROTESTERS, SOME
WEARING MASK AND COURAGEOUS OF
THEM ALL SHE WAS WALKING ON THE
NEW PENN CAMPUS YESTERDAY AND ON
HER WAY TO GIVE A SPEECH.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED.
>> [BLEEP] [BLEEP] GET THE
[BLEEP] OUT!
[BLEEP], [BLEEP], [BLEEP],
[BLEEP], [BLEEP] >> Sean:
CANDACE OWENS JOINS US WITH
MORE.
CANDACE, WHEN I FIRST MET YOU,
WE HAD A VERY DIRECT
CONVERSATION.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER IT.
I REMEMBER WANTING YOU THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WILL HATE YOU FOR
BEING A CONSERVATIVE.
AND AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
AND WHAT I HEARD AND SAW THERE
WAS [BLEEP] CANDACE OWENS,
[BLEEP] THE POLICE BUT I'M SORRY
YOU HAD TO GO THROUGH THAT.
>> Candace: YOU KNOW, I
APPRECIATE THE APOLOGY, BUT I
KNEW WHAT I WAS GETTING INTO
WHEN I GOT INTO THIS.
I DIDN'T REALIZE HOW UGLY IT
WOULD GET.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS THE
TOLERANCE LEFT, BUT I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO HOLD UP
MAYOR LEFT US AND EXPOSE THEM
EXACTLY WHO AND WHAT THEY ARE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU
ACTUALLY SAID SOMETHING, YOU
KNOW, COUPLE OF THINGS THAT YOU
SAID.
BLACK AMERICANS ARE BEING MISLED
BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
UNDER THE EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA,
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY HIS POLICIES EIGHT
YEARS.
TRUMP BECAUSE PRESIDENT AND
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN NANCY
WORKPLACE, BREAKING EVERY RECORD
IMAGINABLE AND EVERY -- THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT ARE WERE HURT THE
MOST UNDER OBAMA'S POLICIES.
WILL THIS BEGIN TO RESIGNATION?
I THINK YOU WILL AGREE WITH ME
BUT TELL ME IF YOU DON'T.
>> Candace: I AGREE WITH YOU
100%.
THIS IS WHAT I WILL ALSO TELL
YOU.
IT IS ALREADY RESONATING.
THAT IS WHY UPPING THEIR ATTACKS
ON ME BECAUSE THEY THINK I'M
PART OF THE REASON RESIGNATION
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
I HAVE SAID THIS, SET THIS ON
YOUR SHOW BACK WHEN I WAS FIRST
ON IT.
THERE WILL BE A BLACK EXIT FROM
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IN 2020 OF THE BLACK VOTE IS
FULLY ON THE TABLE AND THEY ARE
PETRIFIED BECAUSE THEY WILL LIE
ON THE BLACK VOTE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MOVING IT
FIVE POINTS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS TOAST.
THESE ANTICS THAT YOU ARE SEEING
IS FEAR.
THE UPGRADE -- THE UPDATED KKK,
AND COVERING THEIR BASES FOR
HARASSING ME TRYING TO GET ME DE
HARASSING ME TRYING TO GET ME DP
PLATFORM TO.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I SEE YOU STEP INTO THESE
SITUATIONS AND YOU KNEW WHAT YOU
WERE GETTING INTO.
YOU FEEL THE FEAR OBVIOUSLY AND
DO IT ANYWAY.
WHY IS THIS -- IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS IS A CONVICTION INSIDE OF
YOU THAT YOU FEEL PASSIONATE
ABOUT, WHY?
>> Candace: I SPENT A YEAR AND
A HALF RUNNING FROM THESE GUYS.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH SO MANY
KITCHENS, SO MANY EVENTS, GOING
THROUGH BACK DOORS AND HIDING
AND BEING FEARFUL.
I CHANGE MY MIND.
IT IS A NEW POLICY.
I ENCOURAGE ALL BLACK AMERICANS,
WALK THROUGH THE FRONT DOOR.
IF BRIDGET CAN DO IT AT SIX
YEARS OLD IN THE 1960s I CAN